[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum großen corona
quiz mit lutz und lauterbach mein name
ist lutz karl lauterbach und ab dafür
herzlich willkommen es ist ein mega
spannendes quiz haben sie lust hier sehr
gerne kennen sie den mann er highlighter
war kennen sie mich okay wir fangen
trotzdem an nach wie können wir uns nach
jetzigem wissensstand mit corona
infizieren
über tröpfcheninfektion wie groß dürfen
die tröpfchen sein so nie nano ist so
wichtige bereich mal ganz ganz ganz klar
werden kann sozusagen also in soul über
gärten und da war nur ganz kurz diese zu
mache ich hier
ok kann es für uns da aufteilen als
experte da das gleiche story kann
passieren kennen sie den mann gestellt
nicht fest dass das herr professor
doktor doktor lauterbach ist jetzt
richter professor doktor doktor lauter
aber volle punktzahl an der frage dafür
gibt es keine punkte zweig an
streitereien werden wenn ich also warum
sollte man sich nicht die hand geben
wenn der ansteckung sieg
richtig heiß wir haben kleine feier
eingebracht ach so jetzt bin ich drauf
reingefallen man sollte einem mundschutz
masken tragen weil a man vor allem sich
selbst damit schützt b man vor allem
andere schützt oder viele optisch
dazugewinnen
wie war man vor allen anderen schützt
also ich würde sagen b und c also haben
sie konkret jemanden als beispiel der
optisch darzustellen kann den ein oder
anderen kollegen noch was wollt ihr es
hier zu weit gehen die auffällig ist man
sieht sie in letzter zeit ohne fliege
sind die zeiten zu ernst für lustige
verkleidungen
ich musste nahm ich jünger spontaner
aussehen also beim jungen publikum
ankommen da angesagt die pflege wird mir
da nicht also zu arbeiten von daher habe
ich mich im moment etwas mit der pflege
zurückgenommen sie wollen jüngere fans
die frisur ist tatsächlich in
hulu ist und mein friseur eingezogen es
wird kein witz ist obmann ist die
pandemie vorbei wenn wir einen impfstoff
haben werden markus söder ist sagt oder
was machen sie da ja wenn markus söder
sagt also sind sie sich schon sicher ist
dass reja war es dann doch wer meinte
werden markus söder es war ja was heißt
denn blödsinn hier ist ein quiz und sie
haben die antwort genannt kann man dann
hat er hier keinen punkt das ganze nicht
geld ist kein blödsinns gewiss nicht das
ist richtig ist muss er schon wir haben
bisher schon erst den anerkannten wie
war das mit dem fledermäuse die vor dem
verzehr fledermäuse gut durchkochen
wofür steht das r beim erwert robert
koch b reproduktion oder cr ist der
achtzehnte buchstaben im alphabet 18 ist
dreimal die sechs also 666 also steht er
für satan reproduktion b kann man gelten
lassen ja wahnsinn schon wieder richtig
spannend kriegt in die waschmaschine für
eine waschmaschine
ja und ich hier gewinnen es gibt keine
waschmaschine hat es ihnen gefallen hat
spaß gemacht weil sie sich vorstellen
dass das auch eine primetime-show wird
im zdf viertel nach acht wir schmeißen
den kern heraus und trocken das ding
der kern ist definitiv draußen ja kann
ich mir gut vorstellen
da sind wir einer meinung die dann bis
bald zdf 20 15
[Musik]
was denn die über meinen arsch
geigensolo war doch versprochen
ihr könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]